they call it blue gold it's more
valuable to us than any other type of
control the water supply and you're in
charge that's been the case since the
dawn of history the first recorded water
war took place in Mesopotamia 4,500
years ago that's when rival cities
fought over a vital irrigation canal
since then one has remained a big cause
of conflict across the globe ancient
Egypt was totally dependent on the River
Nile it's steady flow of water has
remained vital ever since but since 2011
Ethiopia has been building a dam on the
Blue Nile this has Egyptians worried
about their water supply and they've
threatened war because of it water is
influence water is power why do you
think China is so obsessed with Tibet
water is a big part of that the Tibetan
Plateau slashers are a vital water
source in fact almost half of the
world's population lives near a river
that comes from that glacier but China
is building a lot of dams and the
downstream countries are nervous they're
afraid their water supply will dry up
ruining farms and economies some
countries that had their water sapped
and some didn't have much to begin with
most of the world's water poor countries
are in the Middle East you think the
israeli-palestinian conflict is over
religion it's got much more to do with
land and what's land without water in
the occupied territories the Israeli
military restricts Palestinian water
access with permits and fines so what
may be your water rich in thinking how
does this affect me well a recent
Pentagon report says it's an issue of
national security climate change will
lead to water shortages and global
conflict so water we might not think
about it when it's there but what will
we do and it's not
want more on water check out our running
dry playlist